في تونس تتصاعد ردود الفعل الدولي على
ازمه المهاجرين الافارقه التي تشهدها
البلاد فقد دنت الامم المتحده وصفتها
بحمله القرن التي تستهدف المهاجرين بينما
الولايات المتحده حست على لسان الناطق
باسم خارجيتها السلطات على حمايه اللاجئين
والمهاجرين تعامل السلطات التونسيه مع
ازمه المهاجرين دافع البنك الدولي من جهته
الى ايقاف العمل مع تونس وتعليق اطلاق
استراتيجيه خاصه بها كان الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد قد اتهم بتاجيج حمله التحريض
التي يتعرض لها المهاجرون الافارقه في
البلاد بعد خطاب القاه قبل نحو اسبوعين
شدد فيه على ضروره اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
لوقف تدفق المهاجرين معتبرا ان هذه
الظاهره جزء من ترتيب اجرامي لتغيير
التركيبه الديموغرافيه للبلاد حسب وصفه
اعرب ستيفان دو جاريكا المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده عن قلق
المنظمه الدوليه اذا اما وصفها بحمله
القمع المتزايده التي يتعرض لها المهاجرون
في تونس
للغايه بشان موجه الاعتقالات التعسفيه
التي شهدناها خاصه تلك التي استهدفت
المعارضه السياسيه والمجتمع المدني
والصحفيين وبشان حمله القمع المتزايده ضد
المهاجرين وهو امر مثير للقلق ايضا لا
يسعني الا ان اقول اننا نادين دون تحفظ كل
التصريحات التي تنم عن كراهيه الاجانب
والعنصريه
من جهه اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قلق بلاده من تصريحات الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد بشان المهاجرين الافارقه
وحملات الاعتقال التي استهدفتهم في
الاسابيع الماضيه
الى التنسيق مع المنظمات الدوليه بشان
العوده الامنه والطوعيه للمهاجرين
الراغبين في العوده الى بلداتهم
كما سمعتم من البنك الدولي نحن ايضا نشعر
بقلق عميق ازاء تصريحات الرئيس سعيد بشان
الهجره من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء الى تونس
واجزاء التقارير عن اعتقالات تعسفيه
للمهاجرين في الاسابيع الاخيره هذه
الانباء لا تتماشى مع تاريخ تونس الطويل
من الكرم واستضافه اللاجئين وطالب اللجوء
والمهاجرين وحمايتهم ونحن منزعجون من
التقارير التي تتحدث عن العنف ضدها هؤلاء
المهاجرين نحث السلطات التونسيه على
الايفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب القانون الدولي
وحمايه حقوق اللاجئين وطالب اللجوء
والمهاجرين كما ندعوها الى التنسيق مع
المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه لتسهيل العوده
الامنه والكريمه والطوعيه للمهاجرين
الراغبين في العوده الى بلدانهم
بدورها على الاقل بنك الدولي اطلاق
الاستراتيجيه الخاصه بتونس وقال رئيس
البنك ديفيد ملبس ان البنك اوقف عن عمله
مع تونس بعد تصريحات رئيس قيس سعيد بشان
المهاجره وفي مذكره مواجهه لموظفي قال ان
البنك اوقف اطار عمل الشركه مع تونس مؤقتا
وارجاء اجتماع مجلسه الذي كان مقررا في
هذا الشهر حتى اشعار اخر
وقد اتهمى وزير الخارجيه التونسي نبيل
عمار اطرافا داخليه وخارجه وخارجيه رفض
تسميتها بافتعال وتاجيج ما وصفها بالحمله
التي تستهدف بلادك وقال ان سلطات التونسيه
اتخذت اجراءات لدعم المهاجرين بصفه
قانونيه على اراضيها وتعمل على حمايتهم
نصف لتعرف فما يجب فما عديد الاطراف
لاجندات مختلفه عندها مصلحه اللي هي عندها
مصلحه باشا تهيج شويه الامور موجوده
تكون موجوده داخل وترجم
بارتباط جانب
اخرى هذا شيء واضح ثم تعرفوا الهجره
معناتها فيها برشا معناتها
مصالح ماديه
معروف اللي عنده مصلحه في التجاره هاديه
بالبشر هي تجاره بالبشر في اخر المطاف
نبقى في شان التونسيه حيث قال نور الدين
الطبوبي الامين العام للاتحاد التونسي
للشغل ان الاتحاد على قناعه بان المصالحه
الوطنيه غير ممكنه من دون ما سماها
المحاسبه الشفافه غير الموجهه واضاف
الطبوب في كلمه له بمدينه الحمامات ان
اعضاء الاتحاد ليسوا دعاه سلطه ومواقفهم
واضحه من اجل اخراج البلاد من مناخات
متوتره للغايه وفق تعبيره واشار الطبوبي
الى ان السلطه القائمه في البلاد اعتبرت
مبادره الانقاذ التي قدمها الاتحاد جريمه
وحذر من ان اعضاء الاتحاد مستعدون للتصدي
لاي تهديد ينال من المنظمه النقابيه وان
لديهم مخالب للدفاع عنها حسب التعبير
معنى الان من مدينه الحمامات في تونس
مراسله الجزيره ميساء الفطناسي للوقوف على
هذه الكلمه وابرز الرسائل التي وردت فيها
الامين العام للاتحاد التونسي للشعب
ازدهار بالفعل الرسائل كانت واضحه من
الاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل ومن الامين
العام للاتحاد نور الدين الطبوبي خلال
كلمتها الافتتاحيه في مستهل الاجتماع
المكتبه التنفيذي للاتحاد هذا الاجتماع
الذي يسبق اجتماع الهيئه الاداريه التي
ستكون نهايه الاسبوع الحالي وهي الهيئه
التي تعتبر السلطه الاعلى داخل الاتحاد
والتي تخرج عنها مقررات واجراءات مهمه
اليوم رسائل نريدين الطبوبي كانت واضحه
بان الاتحاد مستهدف على حد تعبيره واعتبر
بانه حتى التحرك الاحتجاجي الذي دعا اليه
الاتحاد ونفذه يوم السبت الماضي ساعه
اطراف الى افشاله ولكنه نجح على الرغم من
ذلك ايضا الاتحاد ونور الدين الطبوبي اتى
على اسباب ومسببات توتر علاقه الاتحاد مع
السلطه التنفيذيه وكانت او لخصها في ثلاث
اسباب تحدي السبب الاول هو ما اعتبره
الاتحاد استهدافا للعمل النقابي من خلال
الملاحقات القضائيه لعدد من القاده
النقابيين السبب الثاني بحسب الاتحاد هو
عدم جديه الحكومه وتنصلها من تنفيذ
الاتفاقات التي سبق توقيعها مع الطرف
النقابي والسبب الثالث ايضا بحسب وضحه نور
الدين الطبوبي اليوم هو رفض السلطه
التنفيذيه لدعوه الاتحاد العامه التونسي
للشغل ومبادراته للحوار الوطني حتى ان
الطبوب اعاد للمره الثانيه توصيف موقف
الحكومه وموقف السلطه التنفيذيه من
مبادرات الاتحاد من دعوتها الى الحوار قال
ان الحكومه وان السلطه التنفيذيه تعتبر
ذلك وكانه جريمه الحوار بالنسبه للسلطه
وكانه جريمه وفي نفس الوقت اكد الامين
العام لاتحاد الشغل نور الدين الطبوبي في
هذا الاطار بان الاتحاد متمسك بطرح
مبادرته الجديده التي ت سمى مبادره
الانقاذ والتي سيتم عرضها على رئيس
الجمهوريه رغم الرسائل والمؤشرات التي
صدرت من الرئيس برفضه لهذه المبادره ولكن
الاتحاد يصر على ان الحوار هو السبيل
الوحيد للخروج من الازمات الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه للبلاد شكرا لك من تونس مراسله
الجزيره ميساء